The European Parliament voted on whether or not
to reduce the red tape farmers faced when applying for the camp
because Finigales MVPs demanded an urgent vote on this important issue.
Our MVPs who were in the Parliament
voted in favour of making the cap simpler for farmers.
The measure was passed, but some Irish MVPs did not support it.
Meps from free to fall and the Green Party voted against the measure.
This is really disappointing,
particularly at the time
when farmers need all the help that they can get.
That's why it's vital to elect MEPs that will support farmers
whenever they can.
Finigale is the only party
that will always stand on the side of farmers
and back measures to make it easier for them to receive CAT support.
That is why this June it is vital that you vote No. 1 Finigale.
For more information visit finigale dot I e.